The New Founding Fathers of America are the
fictional political party known for creating
The Purge.
On their website, they mention some of the
crime sprees in human history that led up
to their inception.
They include a 1971 riot at a New York prison,
the Jonestown massacre in 1978, the Edmond,
Oklahoma post office incident in 1986, and
the LA Riots in 1992.
Those are all real events, so it seems 2014
is where the fictional timeline starts to
diverge from our own.
From 2014, they mention two crime sprees,
The Queensbridge Incident and the Covina Alley
Murders, as events that incited a public outcry
for protection and vengeance against the increasing
number of homeless.
It’s not clear if the actual outcry was
against the homeless, or if the NFFA just
said that as part of their agenda.
Either way it worked, and they began to gain
popularity, due in part to huge donations
from the National Rifle Association, who sought
to protect themselves from the growing movement
to ban firearms.
REPORTER: A new party is arising as a substitute
to the Republicans and Democrats, calling
themselves the New Founding Fathers of America."
Twenty-fourteen was the year that the NFFA
was founded, probably hoping to capitalize
on a time of great civil unrest.
To learn all about their history, as detailed
in the now-defunct NFFA website and how it
gives greater meaning to the events seen in
The Purge movies and TV series, stick around
to the end of this video.
Welcome to Horror History.
Today we’ll be studying a new kind of history,
as I cover The New Founding Fathers of America.
It’s impossible to talk about them without
also covering the history of what they consider
their crowning achievement: The Annual Purge.
The New Founding Fathers were named to bring
thoughts of America’s original founding
fathers who united the colonies of America
in 1776.
They are also sometimes known as the NFA,
the New Founders of America for short.
The NFFA managed to stay in power for nearly
a quarter of a century, so we’ve got a lot
to cover.
Let’s get into it.
The NFFA’s policies have aspects of many
real political parties, but their hidden long
term agenda is profiteering by eliminating
the lower class, which they see as being below
them.
Some of their policies don’t seem so bad,
but they use sneaky language to hide their
true intent.
For example, they claim to support equal opportunity,
but exclude those who they don’t consider
“contributing citizens”.
In other words, employers can’t discriminate
against you for being homeless, but they can
discriminate against you for not contributing
to society, aka, being jobless.
Their most controversial stance, of course,
is their stance on crime.
They claim that aggression is a part of human
nature that needs to be released, so they
planned a science experiment called The Purge
to see if overall crime could be reduced by
containing it all to one night.
More on that later.
They support an investment in eco-technology
to keep the environment clean.
That’s good.
I can get behind that one.
But even here we see that they can’t help
but mention that this is part of an overall
“cleanse” which involves their idea of
“cleansing” out those that are less fortunate.
On the topic of National Security, they plan
to reinstate the military draft in 2023 to
offset the drop in enlistment by impoverished
people and also believe that serving in the
armed forces will better prepare the youth
for purging at home.
This is one of those details that’s disturbing
in so many different ways.
The most messed up part is that it seems to
be part of their effort to brainwash the country’s
youth into becoming killing machines, which
we’ll see more of with their new policies a few
years later.
It seems like the incentive here is to keep
the people battling each other, not battling
the government.
Their take on personal security really shows
their ulterior motives if we analyse it.
Their idea of “security” has more to do
with arming yourself with dangerous weapons,
than creating preventive measures.
It’s very telling that their solution to
violence is more violence, and it is perhaps
the first clue that they are under the thumb
of the gun manufacturing industry, a fact
that is used against them more and more as
time goes on.
Finally, we have their policy on Science and
Technology.
This is perhaps the most puzzling. They claim
to be working with other countries to protect
the US from China’s recent advancements
in space exploration, artificial intelligence
and rejuvenation research.
Artificial intelligence can be used maliciously,
and it is.
But why do we need to protect ourselves from
space exploration and rejuvenation?
There’s something a little fishy about that.
In the time leading up the NFFA taking power,
unemployment continued to rise.
People were protesting, asking for well paying
jobs and an end to police brutality, multiple
wars and a significant dollar devaluation.
REPORTER: Unemployment rising across the nation.
REPORTER #2: Stock market down another 2,000
points in the largest drop in its history.
REPORTER #3: A subprime mortgage crisis worse
than 2008.
REPORTER #4: Neighborhoods across the country
destroyed by an opioid epidemic.
REPORTER #5: Protests across the nation.
Americans are looking for a necessary change
in these tumultuous times.
It seems they first gained office in 2014
with the election of President Bracken.
I guess the election cycle in the world of
The Purge does not line up with that of the
real world, where the new terms began in 2013
and 2017.
“As your elected president, with my fellow
New Founding Fathers, we make this promise.
We will revive this country.
The American dream is dead.
We will do whatever it takes to let you dream
again.”
Just months later, Bracken institutes a controversial
experiment -- one night of legalized crime
in Staten Island known as The Purge, with
the idea that people can get their anger out,
and it will actually reduce crime overall
for the rest of the year.
Interestingly, this solution doesn’t
have anything to do with any of the problems
people have been upset about.
The NFFA’s Chief of Staff, Arlo Sabien,
helped to push the Purge experiment through
Congress, effectively helping put it into
law.
It’s not entirely clear when this occurs.
In Anarchy, we find out that the 2023 Purge
is the 6th Annual Purge.
“The 6th annual Purge will begin in 45 minutes.”
...meaning the first annual purge would have
been 2018.
But we also see in the opening of the original
movie, that there are nationwide Purges in
both 2017 and 2018.
The Experimental Purge only took place on
Staten Island, suggesting that it took place
one year before, in 2016.
“We’re considering a nationwide Purge,
as the people are now calling it, as early
as next year.”
So that leaves the question, if The First
Experimental Purge took place in 2016, and
The First Annual Purge took place in 2018,
what was this nationwide Purge in 2017?
I’m guessing there was a Second Experimental
Purge that year.
The movie, The First Purge, refers to the
experiment as The First Experimental Purge,
which would suggest that there was a Second
Experimental Purge, this time, it would be
a nationwide experiment.
So Bracken took office in 2014, and planned
the first experimental Purge to take place
in 2016, but they would have to employ some
dirty tactics to get this project rolling.
The NFFA takes the public’s perception of
this experimental Purge very seriously, going
so far as to hold auditions for the perfect
voice actress to announce it’s commencement.
“This is not a test.
This is your emergency broadcast system, announcing
the commencement of The Annual Purge, sanctioned
by the US government.
Notice how even before they’ve run their
experiment, the NFFA is already planning to
make The Purge an annual event, evidence that
they never planned to wait for the data from
the experiment -- they already had their minds
made up that they’d be going forward with
it in future years.
The proposition divides the country even further,
and protests break out nationwide, including
conflict between anti-Purge protesters and
those who support the idea of The Purge in North Carolina,
which resulted in at least 20 arrests.
This controversy, which I remind you is a
fictional one, becomes a worldwide issue.
The Pope condemns the idea, and the President
of France calls for a trade embargo with the
US if the experiment is not stopped.
Remember, the NFFA, like a generic hip-hop
video, is all about money, and they would
use it to make sure The Purge Experiment sends
the message they want it to send.
They recruited citizens to participate in
The Purge to try to prove to the rest of the
country that humans naturally need to release
their violence, but rather than rely on their
hypothesis, they interfere by offering money
to low-income citizens who decide to stay
on Staten Island during the experiment for
a payment in the amount of $5000, with additional
incentives for those who participate themselves.
The proposal was also put to vote for Staten
Island citizens, and because the majority
of the population was in a dire financial
situation, they voted Yes on it, much to the
dismay of many pacifists.
The sign up stations are strategically placed
near low income housing projects to try to
get the most desperate people to participate.
Staten Island is also the home of numerous
street gangs that they want to coax into participating.
To try to increase their credibility, Sabien
brings on a behavioural scientist named Dr.
May Updale to run the experiment.
“I do not work for the NFFA.
I did not conceive of the experiment for them.
The NFFA had the courage to test it, but the
conceit is not a political one.
It is a psychological one.
The benefit of acting violently without worry
of consequence, that's a freeing violence.”
However, the NFFA has no plans to run a legitimate
experiment, as Dr. Updale would soon find
out.
Each participant who shows up to Purge is
given a box with a few items: the blue baptisia
flowers, meant to be a symbol of rebirth.
A baptism is a religious ceremony of cleansing
and rebirth, but in this case, the NFFA is
celebrating the violent rebirth of the nation.
They also supply recording contact lenses.
Participants are told these will document
their actions so that they can get paid, but
their main purpose is to broadcast the night’s
events out to the rest of America, helping
push the NFFA’s "violence is a release"
narrative.
They also implant a tracking device on the
Purgers.
Again, while this seems for making sure the
person actually stayed on the island, these
are actually in place for the government to
easily track down and purge anyone they
see unfit for their society.
Arlo Sabien has a backup plan in case organic
participation doesn’t live up to his expectation
and he won't accept any result other than
the one he planned for.
The NFFA surrounds the island with military
forces, ensuring nobody can get off the island,
because that would also not fit their narrative,
they want to make it look like everyone has
just been waiting their entire lives to Purge
and sell the idea that the country as a whole
is excited for it.
Sabien and Updale keep tabs on the happenings
of The Purge in a high tech NFFA facility
nearby, and watch as President Bracken gives
an address before the first sirens sound.
The beginning of the Purge doesn’t go as
Sabien had hoped.
There is graffiti, there’s public drinking,
but very little violent crime; the only fatal
Purge coming from a man who goes by Skeletor
who was already very mentally unstable.
Upon seeing it, Sabien’s top priority is
getting it out to the media for all to see.
There are a couple traps set in the street,
but they don’t turn out to be a real threat,
and the evening goes on.
There’s an armed robbery, but again, no
lives are lost.
Frustration sets in for Arlo Sabien.
SABIEN: “There’s nothing happening.”
EMPLOYEE: “Look at this.
Some kind of block party.”
SABIEN: “Parties?
Are you kidding me?”
Skeletor claims another victim at the block
party, causing Updale to believe that it’s
starting, but it’s still an overall disappointing
showing for Sabien.
SABIEN: “You predicted a much higher level
of participation.”
UPDALE: “We should have expected the unexpected.
This is an experiment.
There are variables.”
SABIEN: The NFFA put a lot of faith into this
evening.
If it's deemed ineffective, the entire regime
could be judged as a failure.”
UPDALE: I told you that science does not obey
the laws of politics.
My job is to analyze this data, nothing more."
Sabien has seen enough and resorts to Plan
B. The NFFA has secretly recruited violent
groups, such as the KKK and hired them to
come in to artificially increase the amount
of purging in order to make it look like regular
citizens had purged.
Suddenly there are Purgers everywhere, and
Updale can’t figure out why.
“All the data supported early violent behaviour,
and then a downturn.
This doesn’t make any sense.”
Sabien warns her not to question it, but of
course, that only makes her more suspicious.
She discovers that after being dispatched
from an abandoned factory in the area, they drove
directly to the most crowded areas.
This causes Updale to realize that they must
have had access to the data from the tracking
chips implanted on the people who stayed on
the island.
In other words, these weren’t just gangs,
they were NFFA hired.
But before she can expose this information
to the public, her snooping around is discovered
by Sabien.
“You’re making it look like people are
participating because there wasn’t enough
purging.”
He explains that he only did it because there
was too much overpopulation, crime, unemployment
and bankruptcy, arguing that the country can’t
afford to care for its own citizens, though
she doubts that the NFFA’s statistics on
such things are even accurate at this point.
“Come on.
Come on.
We both know there's... there's no easy answer
where somebody... some group, doesn't suffer.”
He tells her that her country will remember
her fondly, and has his thugs abduct her and
drop her off in the middle of The Purge where
a group of NFFA henchmen are waiting.
Meanwhile, down on Staten Island, one of the
gang leaders mobilizes his men to try to take
the mercenaries out, which still plays into
the NFFA’s hands; they’re still accomplishing
their mission as long as a lot of fighting
takes place.
And things were about to go down.
Another tactic the NFFA uses to try to create
the impression of greater participation in
the experiment is using attack drones to take
people out.
By doing this, they could eliminate those
that they don’t see fit, while easily hiding
the fact that they were piloting the drones,
making it look like the work of any random
citizen.
The majority of the country never discovers
that the whole experiment was corrupt, but
those who fought for their lives that night
decide to start a resistance, and they would
be the earliest seeds of what would eventually
grow into the NFFA’s biggest detractors.
Ironically, Arlo Sabien runs with the narrative
that the turnout was bigger than they expected,
when really the opposite had been true.
He promises to study the results, and President
Bracken announces that they’re considering
a nationwide purge as early as next year.
“One where every US citizen can participate.”
Before that would occur, the NFFA installs
speakers every 3.7 blocks across the country
so that everyone can hear the sirens announcing
the beginning and end of each Purge.
They also put together surveillance teams
in each city, to document all the activity
that happens during the nationwide experiment.
These surveillance agents, formally known
as the visual analytics department, become
known as the eyes in the sky, and they are
mostly there to enforce the few rules that
do still exist on Purge night, and to prosecute
anyone whose crimes don’t come to a stop
as the final siren sounds.
Of course, they don’t have an agent to keep
an eye on every single purger, but with the
help of an artificial intelligence system
the agents they do have can monitor any activity
that looks suspicious.
On March 14th 2017, one week before the first
national purge, an NFFA team in New Orleans
has a little bit of trouble gaining access
to their secure safe room and in a panic,
call James Sandin, the head and top salesman
of Sandin Security, who installed their system.
This interaction shows that the NFFA doesn’t
even believe in their own policies.
They claim that allowing citizens to own firearms
is the best personal security solution.
What would people say if they saw how nervous
this guy was when he couldn’t get into his
reinforced safety room surrounded by bulletproof
glass?
We only see surveillance footage of this 2017
Nationwide Purge Experiment, but can assume
it played out in a similar way to the Staten
Island Experiment, with the NFFA interfering
to ensure optimal participation.
It was likely not long after that, when the
28th Amendment to the United States Constitution
was ratified, ensuring that The Purge would
be a yearly right to all American citizens.
The bill contains five sections.
Note that the NFA website uses June 7th as
the date of The Purge in order to promote
the release date of the movie, so I’ll just
go ahead and change that screenshot to the
correct dates.
SECTION 1: The Annual Purge shall begin each
year on March 21st at sunset, officially starting
at 7PM, and ending at sunrise, March 22nd,
at 7AM.
SECTION 2: During the time of The Purge, any
and all crime, up to and including murder,
will be legal for 12 continuous hours.
Police, fire and hospital aid will be unavailable
until The Purge concludes.
SECTION 3: The following weapons cannot be
used during The Purge: weapons of mass destruction,
fragment-producing explosives higher than
a hazard class HC/D 1.4 and viral contagion
projectiles.
SECTION 4: Government officials of ranking
5 and higher have been granted immunity from
The Purge and shall not be harmed.
SECTION 5: Non-compliance with any of the
aforementioned rules will result in death
by hanging.
It’s never stated why The Purge takes place
at night, but it's probably as simple as the
fact that crime is more likely to take place
under the cover of darkness, and the NFFA
feels recording technology is good enough
to still be able to identify people in low
light conditions.
The weapon restrictions seem to have more
detail on the website, whereas the PSA in
each movie simply refers to weapons class
4 and lower.
There are other rules that aren’t mentioned
in PSA or the initial iteration of the website,
like the fact that there’s a legal purging
age of 13.
That is, you have to be 13 to Purge, but there’s
no age requirement for being purged.
For whatever reason, Purge travel is tax deductible,
but weapons and security aren’t, at least
not yet.
The immunity for government officials wasn’t
present for the Staten Island experiment,
probably because there were no government
officials staying on the island for that Purge,
so it must have been instituted for the Nationwide
Experiment.
This restriction would continue to change
as time would go on.
The website mentions more of the same lies
we’ve already discussed but it also mentions
the organization’s plans for education.
“The future of our new America relies on
our children.
Over the next four years, we will be working
with states to implement the Federal Purge
Preparation Program (PPP) in all public schools,
as we believe a quality education is necessary
for our youth to become the contributing citizens
of tomorrow.”
I already mentioned how The NFFA wants to
brainwash the next generation of kids by making
them believe that Purging is important to
their well being.
It’s also around this time that the NFFA
fund propaganda filled children’s programming,
teaching children that The Purge is a holiday
to help grown-ups get their worries out.
“By giving them one night, to do whatever
they want!”
“Blessed be our New Founding Fathers.
And America, a nation reborn.”
As I mentioned the blue baptisia flower had
become a symbol of this rebirth, so in 2018,
they would officially designate it as a sign
of support for The Purge, resulting in hundreds
of thousands of people displaying them in
their yards.
With a few purges now having taken place,
America’s population went down, causing
the NFFA to introduce their immigration policy.
This policy uses more tricky language to mislead
people.
It allowed for open borders, but not really
because they say those deemed undesirable
by the populace will be purged as such.
There had already been accusations of racial
inequality by the NFFA during the Staten Island
Experiment, because the demographics of the
neighborhoods that were hardest hit had darker
skin, but this new immigration policy pretty
much confirmed it.
In 2019, something called The Great Integration
occurred.
“Led by the NFA, it eliminated party-line
bickering and established the highest political
consensus since the nation's first hours of
independence.”
There was also a law called the Contributing
Citizens Provision of 2019 which as I mentioned
earlier, appears to ban discrimination, but
contains the caveat that they must be what
the NFFA defines as contributing citizens.
The year 2020 saw the establishment of the
Purge Injury and Disability Act.
Their take on healthcare is very similar to
their take on civil rights.
They plan to provide healthcare, but only
to those who don’t really need that much
healthcare.
This is a money saving scheme, which impacts
those with disabilities and those with injuries,
especially if they can’t afford treatment
of their own.
A big kicker is that there is only one area
that’s truly immune to the Purge: the hospital.
The desire to only permit the survival of
those who fit their view of what a perfect
ideal human looks like is very similar to
the Nazi’s idea of only having a single
Arian race.
We’ve already seen them working with the
KKK and the NFFA would also attract Neo-Nazis
for those same reasons.
Twenty-twenty was also the year that a bill
was introduced to the The US Senate that would
extend the length of The Purge from 12 hours
to 18 hours.
Despite several years of trying, this bill
was never passed, though I should note that
the NFFA dominated the senate at this point,
as this was after the Great Integration, so
the bill was being debated within the New
Founding Fathers party.
Senator Charles Bixby from California was
one of the politicians that supported the
extension, while Roger Ellis from TX opposed
it.
They continued their conquest to brainwash
the youth in 2021 with the American Historical
Act, which legally ensured that all students
be taught the history and perspective necessary
to -- as they put it -- understand the pre-Purge
ills which nearly collapsed this great nation.
Basically, they’re going to make sure that
all schools tell their students that The Purge
saved the country, making it look like an
indisputable fact that the annual evening
of mayhem is actually a good thing.
“Well, we studied the history of tonight
in history…”
The time leading up to The Fifth Annual Purge
in 2022 would be some of the NFFA’s busiest
and most dastardly years, and they continued
to take action behind the scenes to manipulate
the American people.
By the conclusion of The Fourth Annual Purge
in 2021, the NFFA had a massive legion of
sheep-like followers that would listen to
anything they had to say just because it was
coming from the NFFA.
Whichever side you’re on, I’m sure you
think that probably sounds familiar.
The New Founding Fathers would take to the
internet to further push their agenda, by
taking great lengths to make the Purge seem
like a normal, patriotic holiday.
They post red, white and blue martini recipes
on their blog, and give out tips for an environmentally
friendly Purge.
Gotta give respect to them where due for sticking
with the environmentally friendly thing.
There aren’t too many evil organizations
that will do that for us.
They brag about their impressive numbers when
it comes to low unemployment.
The rate is down to 1%, but it’s not because
they fixed the economy, but rather because
the unemployed can’t afford to protect themselves
on Purge night.
If they aren’t alive, they aren’t unemployed.
“An official report by the Founders Economic
Advisory projected that this year’s Purge
could reduce unemployment to an unprecedented
low of 0.85%.”
They try to make it look like this is because
of new jobs created by the Purge preparation
industry, but remember, because of their 2019
provisions, the ones who need jobs under the
NFFA regime aren’t really the ones that
are getting those jobs.
Thanks to their government intervention, and
thanks to their skewing of collected data,
releasing the beast during The Purge was becoming
more and more popular, and the NFFA, backed
by the behemoths of the gun industry, always
have financial incentive to make it bigger.
They post tips on literally dressing to kill,
making their murder promoting propoganda seem
as innocuous as a basic fashion blog.
The blog also explores combat rituals from
other cultures in an attempt to make the United
States’ yearly night of legal violence seem
a little bit more normal.
They also try to convince people that science
says violence is essentially part of our DNA;
that it’s natural for us to want to release
our anger.
The study is conducted by Dr. Peter Buynak,
who I’ve theorized is under the thumb of
the NFFA, and after seeing the fate of Dr.
Updale, it’s easy to see why he might comply.
They also air his interviews on TV, giving
Americans the false impression that purging
will solve their problems.
BUYNAK: “The countrywide catharsis creates psychological
stability, by letting us release the aggression
we all have inside of us.”
In Michigan the government re-uses a tactic
from Staten Island, offering $250 per purge
bounty, but of course, only if you’re employed-full
time, they couldn’t have the homeless taking
advantage of that.
Twenty-twenty-two also marked a fifth consecutive
year that crime rates went down, however,
those numbers may need to be taken with a
grain of salt seeing as how they come from
the New Founders Institute of Justice.
It seems that no organization is safe from
The New Founding Fathers’ reach and corruption.
Including the postal service.
Imagine living in a world where the government tries to corrupt the postal service.
If the numbers are to be believed though,
this is likely the height of the public’s
support for The Purge with 88% supporting
the 28th amendment.
Finally the government immunity is decreased
for the next Purge.
Where previously all officials of rank 5 and
above were granted immunity, now you would
have to rank at least 10 to receive immunity,
and no I don’t know what that means, but
I do know that US senators and anything higher
than that are still protected.
When March 21st finally arrived, the Purge
once again received record participation.
One family in California, which happens to
be the family of the security mogul I mentioned
earlier, James Sandin, has a tumultuous Purge
night when their teenage son lets in a homeless
man being chased by a group of purgers.
They break in and ultimately, James and a
few of his neighbors lose their lives, but
the homeless man, Dante Bishop, is saved and
vows to put a stop to the NFFA.
That morning, hundreds of people gather in
Times Square for a public vigil to thank all
those who were killed to make the country
a safer place, a demonstration of how the
NFFA’s manipulation of public opinion is
working.
But the markets continue to soar… at least
for gun and security system companies, which
of course, all benefits the dystopian political
party.
They would put this newfound income to use
in their marketing department.
As part of an attempt to seamlessly intertwine
their party and The Purge with American culture,
they revamp their website and release a line
of Purge paraphernalia.
We’re talking shirts, hats, bumper stickers
and koozies.
I know I’m not supposed to talk about real
politics, so I’ll just say, wowwww this
was accurate!
They also try to get in with the pop-culture
crowd by working with Hollywood star Lacey
Demontgomery.
Her interview appeared in a January 2023 Issue
of We Weekly Magazine, where she discussed
her plans for the upcoming Purge.
They also do their weapon manufacturer friends
a favor by publishing a list of the Top 5
gadgets for purging, the most unsettling of
which is an app called Finders Keepers that
can monitor the GPS location of any cell phone
that is turned on during The Purge, making
it easy for purgers to find and kill their
enemies or friends.
One of the most deceptive political tactics
used by the NFFA is making the public feel
like they’re in control, when in fact, they
could not be more subjected to near totalitarian
rule.
We saw that in 2016, when they allowed Staten
Island to vote on if they wanted to host The
Purge Experiment, and we see it again, as
they allow their followers to go online to
vote on potential new measures to add to the
Purge.
However, if you read them, you may notice
that these are all measures that benefit the
NFFA with one possible exception.
I’ll list them from most popular to least
popular and explain how they help the NFFA
and harm the average citizen.
Measure D:
Make Purge and Purge Security Expenses Tax
Deductible.
This would encourage more spending on Purge
related items, which means these sellers can
donate more money to the NFFA, making them
more powerful.
It would also probably cause prices to increase,
making it even harder for the poor to defend
themselves.
Measure C: Raise the Legal Purging Age from
13 to 16.
Thirteen to fifteen year olds make up about
19% of fatalities on Purge night.
It benefits the NFFA for them to survive long
enough to buy their own weapons.
Since they can’t work until they’re at
least 16, the older demographic is more likely
to purchase a gun.
Measure G: Allow State Governments To Pass
Local Purge Laws.
This is the one exception that I mentioned,
but it could also benefit the NFFA
if it means they’re able to pass new legislation
faster without having to go through the federal
government.
Measure F: Loosen Weapon Restrictions.
More weapons, more purging.
Measure E: Ban disguises.
This would make it easier for the eyes in
the sky to find enemies of the NFFA so they
can be taken out.
Measure B: Replace The Failed Social Security
Scheme With A Contribution-based Purge Pension
Plan.
This reduces the NFFA spending on the elderly,
who they don’t care about because they’re
unlikely to purge.
And Measure A: Extend the Annual Purge Hours.
A longer purge means more purging can take
place.
It’s not known if any of these measures
were ever put into law, but the New Founding
Fathers’ next venture world see them for
the first time meddling in the video game
industry.
In the months leading up to the sixth annual
Purge, shooting galleries were crowded with
people looking to get some practice in before
the big night, leading many to try to find
alternative forms of practice.
Brown University did a study on the effect
of video games on handgun accuracy, and found
that first person shooters can help improve
a person’s aim and response time by 15%
and 30% respectively.
The New Founding Fathers ran with this idea,
publicising the stats to help encourage gamers
to rise up on Purge night.
"You don't seem to understand, that there are skills that CS:GO teaches you that school just can't teach!"
There’s also a Purge arcade game that goes
into development.
It’s not entirely clear to what extent the
NFFA is involved, but you just know they probably
had a hand in anything that glorifies The
Purge.
Such as this Purge student art initiative
backed by the wife of New Founding Father
J Adams Swift, where a 4th grader won $1,000
for writing a haiku that promoted the Purge.
The final statement the group made before
the 2023 Purge was in response to a group
of internet videos created by a resistance
fighter named Carmelo Johns claiming that
his group would be fighting back against the
NFFA this year.
The NFFA falsely claimed that they'd investigated
this threat, and found that the video traced
back to a lone individual, not an organization.
The reason they claimed that the rebellion
was a hoax was to discourage any of their
opponents to try to join it and to fit their
narrative that The Purge is a good thing for
the country, a now beloved holiday tradition.
As they have since the Staten Island experiment
seven years before, The NFFA would send their
own people out into this year’s Purge to
supplement the purging, however, things get
out of hand in Los Angeles, where Carmelo
Johns and his men take out an entire truck
full of the NFFA’s mercenaries.
An ex-cop named Leo Barnes also gives them
trouble, taking out several NFFA hired purgers
and saving four would-be victims.
To make matters worse, Johns hacks into the
NFFA’s Purge countdown stream at the halfway
point and delivers a message about the true
purpose of The Purge.
“Profit making is not the essence of democracy.
Wake up people.
Wake up!
It’s time to take a stand.
Tonight we write our message in blood!”
At the end of the night, the rebellion breaks
in to a Purge Gala where rich donors pay absurd
amounts of money to hunt down homeless people
and other people who have been captured on
the streets in a controlled environment.
Johns, Dante Bishop, and several others spoil
the whole party, but outside of this hiccup
in LA, the night is once again an overall
success for the administration in power, once
again taking the title as the deadliest Purge.
I was going to call it the purgiest purge
but that sounds kind of silly.
But this may have been a contributing factor
to the opening of a Purge Memorial Park in
Washington DC in Spring 2024.
Citizens could order a brick to commemorate
their support for the NFFA or the loss of
a loved one during the Purge -- yet another
grim example of the group using killing to
drive sales and profits.
They would eventually take this one step further
by instituting a yearly Remembrance Day to
honor those who lost their lives during The
Purge.
PSA: “This weekend is a time to honor and
celebrate those great martyrs, who gave their
lives for our country.”
Delivery Man: “Thank you for your sacrifice.”
PSA: “Take time this holiday to remember,
there is no greater act of service, than to
give your life for our great nation.”
This subconsciously encourages people to go
out during the Purge, because if they do lose
their lives, they can at least be remembered
as heroes.
Remembrance Day would take place on June 21st,
three months after The Annual Purge.
Over the next several years, the rebellion
is still working behind the scenes, but most
of the country has basically begrudgingly
accepted The Purge as a part of life.
In order to continue to prove to their supporters
that The Purge is “working” and to keep
their detractors living in fear, the NFFA
must continue to find new ways to increase
participation year after year.
We’ve seen them tie The Purge into many
aspects of life, like pop-culture and religion,
and it wouldn’t be long before it also leaked
into business.
Since the NFFA’s policies help the rich
get richer, many of their biggest supporters
are extremely wealthy and hold Purge night
parties where they get their biggest business
deals of the year done, using the opportunity
to pressure their business partners into joining
up with NFFA and maybe even do a little purging
themselves.
On the flip side, it’s been well established
that the NFFA’s biggest targets are the
homeless, sick and vulnerable.
In other words, the people who require care
that requires government spending.
“The NFFA doesn’t care about protecting
drug addicts and alcoholics.
We have to lock down like everyone else.”
But they aren’t just denying them protection
-- they’re also actively working on programs
to see that these people are purged.
In New Orleans, at some point they hired a
social worker named Tavis to form a sham-religion
called The Mercy Cult.
She would meet these recovering teens at their
lowest point and convince them that they can
cleanse their souls and become Gods and Goddesses
by giving themselves up; by stepping out of
their flesh to enter The Invisible.
“Purify my flesh.
Prepare my soul.
The giving is near.
The invisible awaits.”
She convinces them that their souls are irreparably
damaged by the drug use, and giving their lives is the only
way to cleanse themselves.
These kids were also easy targets, because
having just come out of rehab, they would
have no access to the caregivers they had
grown accustomed to, so they were even more inclined
to find something else to lean on, someone
who seemed to care for them.
“I will be your guide into the invisible.
Where there is no pain, only love.
Tavis dubbed herself as the “Good Leader”
of the cult and created a whole program where
she would teach the kids how to prepare themselves
for The Invisible.
Once they got older and reached their late
teens, they would graduate from yellow robes
to light blue ones that matched the official
color of the NFFA and the blue baptisias that
represent rebirth or baptism.
On the eve of their “giving”, they are
to shower, another symbol of the cleanse.
They spend the afternoon joining together
in prayer, then she leads them to a light
blue school bus.
But this was no game of Fortnite.
Every Purge, the bus would travel around the
city, making several stops, and at each one,
the cult would chant in prayer as Tavis would
“select” one victim.
She would pretend to be some kind of shaman
who could receive messages from The Invisible
telling her whose turn it was at each stop.
Then, that person would get off the bus, where
a group of purgers was waiting, and the rest
of the group would watch as the person is
either purged or taken somewhere where they
would later be purged.
It’s not known exactly how long Tavis ran
this cult or how many innocent teens lost
their lives as a result of this, but it comes
to an end during the 10th Annual Purge in
2027.
Actually, it seems they weren’t entirely
sure about the date with this stuff, but it
makes more sense that this document would
be a mistake than the computer for their security
system being wrong.
Anyway, a Marine named Miguel Guerrero comes
home looking for his sister and tracks down
The Mercy Cult bus.
Tavis’s affiliation with the NFFA is exposed,
and she falls victim to The Purge.
However, this was most likely just one chapter
in of this cult in one city, so it was probably
just a small L for the New Founding Fathers,
not a total victory royale, but not a bad
finish either.
The next known activity occurs during the
19th annual Purge, when an NFFA surveillance
agent named Esme Carmona notices some strange
activity in District 2 of New Orleans.
While on the lookout for illegal activity
during the 19th Purge on March 22nd, 2036
Esme Carmona notices a professor that she
knows, out during The Purge, which she finds
very strange.
ESME: “Oh no.
That’s Drew Adams.”
VIVIAN: “You know her?
ESME: “She h*ted this holiday.
She wouldn’t be outside.”
If you're wondering how I know it's the 2036
Purge, it has to be after 2032, because there's
a 14 year flashback to another Purge, and
based on how the characters act, it isn't
the first.
But it has to be before 2037, because Ryan
uses an ID that expires in late 2036, and
it works.
There is no Saturday June 15 in that date
range, but there is a Saturday July 19th in
2036.
The “eyes in the sky” agents aren’t
supposed to bring personal relationships into
their work, but Esme becomes obsessed after
watching her close friend get purged on camera,
and decides to do some secret investigating
on her own.
She discovers that Professor Adams’s home
was invaded by NFFA soldiers and comes to
the conclusion that it wasn’t random.
Her superior at the office realizes what she’s
up to and threatens to reprimand her if she
doesn’t stop.
“.... So take some time off, grieve for your friend,
then let it go.”
So she uses the free time to take to the streets
to try to find out why her friend was targeted.
She recovers some evidence from her house
that suggests she'd been conducting some kind
of independent study on the human brain before
she was purged.
Esme gets in contact with one of her students,
looking for answers.
In June 2036, the student finds her that answer
when he reveals that Professor Adams was trying
to hide her study, because it had found proof
that the NFFA had been lying about the effects
of The Purge on human behaviour.
Their behavioral scientist Dr. Peter Buynak had
concluded that Purging was a catharsis, that
people could “let out” their aggression
and be fine for the rest of the year.
Professor Adams’s study said the opposite,
claiming that engaging in violence will likely
lead to the desire for more violent behaviour.
“Those brain scans show that violent actions
can light up the pleasure centers of the brain
like a drug.
Especially those in the younger generation,
those who grew up with the 28th amendment.
I’d like to point out AGAIN that The Purge
is a work of fiction, and I do not know if
Prof. Adams or Dr. Buynak's findings are true;
and to be honest, I’m not going down that
rabbit hole in this video.
They speculate that everything the NFFA has
been saying about crime rates going down after
the institution of The Purge may have been
false data.
Esme realizes she could find Professor Adams’s
anonymous test subjects using the facial recognition
technology at her job.
This would be risky, because she’s not supposed
to use the equipment for personal reasons,
but it would help her verify the results of
the study.
Esme’s boss notices her transgressions and
begins spying on her every move with the interests
of protecting the NFFA’s dirty secrets.
He doesn't want them to be just another regret.
I'm fired.
This eventually causes her to have to go on
the run from the law in November as she continued
her investigation.
All but one of Professor Adams’s test subjects
were taken out along with her during the 19th
Purge, and that one that they couldn’t get
to was illegally killed off-purge by the NFFA,
and it was covered up.
So essentially, when Carmelo Johns and Dante
Bishop started the anti-NFFA revolution 13
years before, they only knew about half of
the sins the party had committed.
The reason they were able to stay in power
so long was because they were using The Purge
to take out anyone who might threaten their
regime.
So the Purge wasn’t just a way for them
to make money by killing the groups they don’t
like, but it was also the single biggest factor
contributing to keeping them in power.
Esme is able to navigate the street to learn
all of this, because she knows where all the
dead zones are with no cameras.
However, she’s not able to evade them forever.
She dodges a taser from an undercover FBI
agent, which hilariously hits a random woman,
and Esme goes on the run with her entire former
workplace trying to track her movements.
“We worked side by side with Esme.
She was part of our family.
But she has committed an act of treason, and
now it is our job to protect this country,
by catching her.”
The search for Esme becomes a priority-1 manhunt,
meaning that the higher powers of the NFFA
have given the visual analytics team access
to private cell phone cameras in an attempt
to locate her faster.
She does have one friend on the inside though
-- a woman who worked at the desk behind her
named Vivian.
Esme tries blending into what appears to be
a crowd of riled up sports fans, but one of
their cell phones captures her face, and the
area is soon surrounded by armed NFFA SWAT
guys.
She slips away to hide out in a warehouse
owned by this guy she kind of knows.
His name is Ryan Grant, and he’s an ex-cop
who now robs banks during The Purge.
He gives her a place to lie low for a while
in exchange for her helping him out on his
next heist with her inside knowledge of how
the NFFA operates.
Meanwhile, Esme brainstorms on how she’s
going to expose Professor Adams’s research
to the public.
“The NFFA just issued an alert.
All citizens should be on the lookout for
Esme Carmona.
Looks like you’re public enemy number 1.”
I’m just gonna assume that he manually removed
all the cameras from that phone and didn't
stupidly give her up to the NFFA by pointing
them at her.
Right?
That must be what happened??
Please?
She helps Ryan and his team perfect their
bank heist plan for the next Purge, and Vivian
fills her in on what’s going on at the surveillance
center.
The eyes in the sky expect Esme to make her
move on Purge night, so everyone is alerted
to look out for her.
When the big night arrives, Vivian and Esme
meet in secret 3 hours before commencement,
and Emse asks her to falsely tag her in the
system in order to distract the NFFA and allow
the real Esme some wiggle room to pull off
her plan.
“That was a false hit on Esme.
Strike team couldn’t find any sign of her.”
“Oh.
It looked like her.
I’m sorry.
I’m just anxious to bring her in.”
Meanwhile, Esme sneaks off to a secret warehouse
full of hackers, who are standing by to amplify
her message to as many screens as possible
when the time comes.
They also use a deep fake hologram of Esme
to draw the guards of the surveillance center
away from their posts.
"Right now you are walking down a street near
that NFFA building and there is absolutely
no way they can tell it’s fake.”
It works.
Esme’s former boss dispatches his first
floor security team as she sneaks up to the
back door of the surveillance center.
She uses a piece of technology known as a
jammer to basically knock out the power in
the entire building.
I know, kind of OP.
Unfortunately this is the only time the existence
of jammers are acknowledged in the Purge universe
so far.
She has a 60 second window to break into the
building.
Then she climbs up an IT tunnel to break into
the server room and access the footage of
the NFFA breaking into an innocent woman's
house.
The NFFA probably scrubbed the main surveillance
camera footage out of existence, but this
is coming from dash cam footage on a postal
van that they are unlikely to know about.
So she's basically using their Orwellian cameras-everywhere surveillance against them.
She also discovers proof that they are killing
citizens off-Purge.
She finds that they’ve stepped up their
security since her departure and the ability
to transfer files off the servers has been
revoked.
The monitors also have some kind of screenshot
blocking technology, so she improvises.
“The file was protected, I couldn’t transfer
it outside the closed system.”
“Don’t tell me this was all for nothing.”
“I could transfer the file within the system,
so I did… to the broadcast room.”
Vivian informs her that it’s way too risky.
Once she started broadcasting, she’d essentially
be a sitting duck, and it was Purge, so there’s
no telling what they might do to her.
But that’s a risk that Esme is willing to
take.
Vivian does her part by creating a distraction
for her fellow co-workers.
Or at least… trying to create a distraction.
“Uh, everyone.
Uhm.
Everybody.
I just, uhm, I just want to say thank you
for making my first yea here…
YEAR* here, so wonderful…
And uhm, let’s not miss anything this year.
Thank you..."
ASSASSIN'S CREED MERCHANT: "That won't happen here!"
ASSASSIN'S CREED MERCHANT: "Where is the one responsible for this?!"
Needless to say, one of them reports the sus
activity to the boss and he intercepts Esme
and Vivian in the stairwell.
Vivian takes the bullet for Esme, who promptly
strikes back before infiltrating the broadcast room.
This causes sirens to sound all over the building
and practically an army of guards to swarm
Esme, but with the added assistance of Ryan,
who shows up to save her, she’s able to
stay alive just long enough to get her message
out to the world.
ESME: "You know what she found? Proof that Purge doesn’t take away our anger,
our h*tred and our fears.
It fuels them.
The reason I’m being hunted, is because
I discovered the truth.”
Esme shows the video just as The Purge ends,
and even though she should theoretically be
safe until next year's Purge, the NFFA takes
her out, once again proving her claim that
they’re taking out their opponents off-Purge.
However, what that officer didn’t realize
was that Esme never took the broadcast off
the air.
It became the shot heard round…
New Orleans...
The NFFA would try to calm down the public
by making the claim that what happened on
that broadcast was all fake news.
This was enough to convince a good amount
of their supporters, but more than ever, people
were waking up to their lies.
I really am tired of the whole "wake up people"
cliche, but I couldn't think of a better word
to say right there… so...
As usual, the Purge death toll is as high
as it ever has been, but more and more people
are realizing that many of these deaths aren’t
the result of PvP kills, or in this case,
citizen on citizen purging.
Two months later, in April of 2037, Vivian,
who somehow survived the 20th Annual Purge,
joined the resistance, which is bigger than
ever thanks to Esme’s contributions.
The American citizens are getting angrier
and angrier, and for the first time in years,
new independent politicians are getting support
in the polls.
This political tension would reach a breaking
point in 2040.
“This is just one of a dozen protests around
our capital after reports emerged claiming
that the New Founding Fathers had been using
the Purge to help their own economic agenda.”
The Presidential Office is up for re-election
once again, and as usual, an NFFA candidate
is the favorite, but this time not by a very
wide margin.
“Establishment NFFA candidate Minister Edwidge
Owens has been losing ground to wildcard Independent
candidate Senator Charlie Roan.”
Roan’s campaign rides on her promise to
put an end to The Purge.
During an emergency meeting at the White House,
the incumbent President Caleb Warrens expresses
his concern about senator Roan’s chances.
He announces his disgust with the public,
calling them “idealistic pigs” and claiming
that not everyone in a society can have it
all -- there simply isn’t enough to go around.
He stands before them, in his $20M board room,
and proclaims that it’s time to do something
about the NFFA’s detractors, like Bishop
and Roan.
“We are going to use this year’s Purge
to do some Spring cleaning gentlemen…”
Day 9429.
They still have not realized that I’m not
one of the boys.
Section 4 of the 28th amendment would see
yet another change, this time with the immunity
for government officials being removed altogether.
When the NFFA Press Secretary Tommy Roseland
presents this news, he tries to make it about
fairness.
His reasoning for removing the exemption is
to even the playing field, so the rich and
powerful are on the same level as the average
citizen.
However, it’s clear to Roan’s administration
that this is really all about purging her
out of the picture so they can easily take
the election.
It’s not like the rich and powerful elite
still won’t be able to use their money to
protect themselves, just like they have every
year.
The next debate does well for Senator Roan.
Minister Owens announces he’ll be presiding
over his party’s Midnight Purge Mass, the
next step in the evolution we’ve seen across
the NFFA’s history towards integrating The
Purge into some kind of religion.
Roan gains the sympathy of many voters by
caring for the low-income individuals who
are the most endangered demographic during
The Purge, and spiteing the NFFA and their
sponsors who benefit from it.
By removing the exemption for government officials,
the NFFA has put Roan in a tough spot.
She can either stay home, and risk being
purged, or she can lock herself up in a high
security safehouse, making her look rich and
unrelatable to her low-income voter base,
thus causing her to lose votes and probably
lose the election.
So she decides to stay home, and let her security
detail line the inside of the house with guards.
Unfortunately for her, this is exactly what
the NFFA was expecting, and they had men on
the inside.
I guess Eric and Chief Couper were New Founding
Fathers who took a job as part of Roan’s
security team some time ago as an insurance
policy for the NFFA.
Not sure how they got around the background
check, but I’ll just assume the NFFA have
people in high places to where something like
a background check can easily be fabricated.
Couper pulls a Saw 2 on the security cameras
so that they’re playing back recorded footage
instead of a live feed, and Eric dismisses
two of the guards by the front door, so that
nobody sees when all the men outside the house
are sniped down.
He quietly disarms the security system and
lets the NFFA’s assassins into the senator’s
home.
This time the NFFA has hired a unit of neo-Nazi
henchmen, contuing the tradition of working
with modern factions of the very worst groups
in human history.
Many of the villains that I cover here on
Horror History have some kind of a gray area
in their morality, but it's clear we're supposed
to see the NFFA as just pure evil.
They sweep the lower level, then make their
way upstairs to the den when Roan is being kept.
Eric has all the security credentials to get
them into the room, but when they arrive,
they discover that she’s already escaped with
her head security guard, Leo Barnes.
The leader of the assassins is Earl Danzinger,
a mercenary covered from literal head to toe
in the symbols of terrorist groups.
He tells his men that Roan and Barnes may
be outside and has them check the perimeter,
but not long after, they are spotted by Couper
from the window.
One of the snipers, Tommy, fires at them,
and manages to hit Barnes in the shoulder
with a tracking bullet, but he has a clever
counter-attack, detonating a remote bomb he
left behind in the room that takes out everyone
besides Tommy, who barely survives and loses
consciousness; Danzinger, who had already
stepped outside; and the men who were already
outside searching the perimeter.
I’m guessing that qualifies as higher than
a class 4 explosive, but obeying The Purge’s
rules was probably the least of their concerns
right now, plus Roan could always pardon him
after she’s won the election.
Danzinger orders his men to search the streets
while he searches the skies.
I think at this point they don’t realize
that the tracking bullet actually stuck in
Leo’s shoulder, so they don’t think to
check that right away.
Danzinger commands his men from the helicopter,
when he receives word that Tommy regained
consciousness.
Tommy lets them know about the tracking bullet,
so from that point they’re able to find
him and the senator fairly quickly, and shoot
at the triage van they’re traveling in from
the chopper.
They circle back around for another round,
but the van turns unexpectedly and hides under
the freeway, which suggests to Danzinger that
she’s probably still alive.
“We’re gonna lose em under there.
Ground unit.
Get you ***es moving and get here now, we’ve got
them cornered.”
The ground unit follows the location of the
bullet.
They take the truck as far as they can, then
go on foot to the waterfront, where they find
the bullet discarded on the ground.
Just as they realize they’ve been hoodwinked,
bamboozled, led astray, ruck amok, and flat
out deceived, they’re also ambushed by an
aggressive group of gang members, and the
last thing Danzinger hears from them over
the headset is gunshots, and the celebration
of their defeat.
He commands his people to search every traffic
cam in the city to find the triage van.
Later that night, they find it, and at the
request of minister Edwidge Owens, capture
the senator alive.
They bring her to the Our Lady of Sorrow church,
but they were not there to solve the mystery
of laceration gravity, but rather to sacrifice
Senator Roan in the holiest way they know
how at Midnight Purge Mass.
Once inside the cathedral, she’s knocked
unconscious and dressed in a white gown, to
be presented to Edwidge Owens and the rest
of the NFFA congregation.
Together they recite the NFFA anthem and Owens
gives a sermon, with a little bit of a psychotic
energy.
“We’ll sin, scour, sanitize and sterilize
our souls, until we are free again!
And this country will be better for it!”
The first purge of the evening is a martyr
named Lawrence, who Owens notes was a lifelong
drug addict, to keep the NFFA on brand with
their desire to purge those who may require
government assistance.
Roan is brought out to be the next victim,
the most ceremonious one of the evening.
He invites all of the Founding Fathers to
the altar to join, to -- as he puts it -- “purge
as one”, but before President Warrens can
do the honors, they are attacked by the rebellion,
and for the first time, the President of the
United States is legally purged.
Chaos breaks loose and a huge firefight erupts,
where many secret service agents get purged,
but through everything, both presidential
candidates manage to survive.
Owens hides in a chamber below the church,
but he’s captured by Bishop’s troops.
When Dante puts the gun to his head the minister
actually begs to be purged.
I think this is less of a case of Owens actually
starting to believe in his own phony religion,
and more of a case of Owens actually having
been so brainwashed by his political party,
he genuinely starts to value their success
over his own life.
If he’s taken out, he becomes a martyr,
and it’s likely that the NFFA rallies around
his replacement and it benefits their success
overall.
Or maybe that isn’t it all.
Maybe Minister Owens knows he’s going to
lose the election after people discover what
he has in the next room.
More than 10 people are kidnapped, and it’s
likely that he planned on purging all of them
as part of the religious ceremony.
Seeing this outrages Senator Roan, and she
vows to destroy him on election day.
After one last battle, Barnes and Bishop are
able to take down Danzinger and his men, as
well as The NFFA priest, Harmon James.
Much was sacrificed, but Roan and Owens both
survive the night in order to make it to election day.
Two months later on May 26th 2040, the ballots
are cast, and Senator Roan keeps her promise
by winning Florida, to push her over the top
and take the election.
After more than 25 years the evil and corrupt
regime known as The New Founding Fathers of
America would finally come to an end.
With her first executive action, President
Roan would put a stop to The Purge.
While the NFFA’s reign over the executive
office had come to a conclusion, their supporters
weren’t about to go down without a fight.
“We’re just now hearing reports about
a few scattered incidents around the country
where NFFA supporters are reacting violently
to this defeat, they are burning cars, breaking
windows, looting, attacking police officers…”
But with the NFFA now out of office, I’m
going to go ahead and end this video.
Hopefully this helped you better understand
how the NFFA operates and what their true
goals and motivations were.
If you love the Purge I’ve got more content
on the way.
So go ahead and subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for all notifications, and I’ll see you
in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
And like the Purge, I recommend you stay home,
but if you do have to go out, wear a mask.